madame la ministre merci
d'avoir répondu à l'invitation de la
commission qui a démarré l'ensemble de
ces auditions dans la perspective du
budget 2023 et nous sommes donc
particulièrement heureux de vous
accueillir ainsi que Louise Vassy votre
l'ambassadeur Louise Vassy votre
directeur de cabinet et l'équipe qui
vous accompagne alors bien évidemment je
donnais on va parler un peu budget par
les chiffres par les pourcentages mais
je pense que l'échange que nous allons
avoir doit aussi nous permettre
d'évoquer votre vision et votre analyse
sur l'état du monde qui n'est pas très
monde qui ne se porte pas vraiment très
bien en ce moment et donc je pense que
la position de la France
est très importante je pense que vous
pourrez en profiter pour l'expliciter à
travers le jeu des questions et des
réponses qui vont intervenir mais pour
l'instant limitons nous peut-être si
vous voulez bien dans un premier temps à
la dimension budgétaire qui mérite
d'être salués puisque les autorisations
d'engagement de votre ministère
progresse de 16%, les crédits de
paiement progressent de 9 % je tiens à
saluer cet effort alors bien évidemment
ce taux global marque des différences
mais qui s'atténue toutefois par rapport
à l'année dernière avec une augmentation
importante de 13% des moyens de l'aide
publique au développement mais nous
étions plutôt habitués dans les années
précédentes à voir ces crédits augmentés
mais surtout ce qui nous intéresse c'est
de constater la hausse de 5% de l'action
extérieure de l'État
alors bien sûr tout peut paraître
insuffisant au regard du niveau atteint
par l'inflation puisque globalement 5%
c'est le taux d'inflation sur lequel
nous courons actuellement enfin je
souhaite néanmoins saluer cet effort
nouveau par rapport à des années où nous
avons plutôt assisté à décompression
budgétaires nous aurons l'occasion d'y
revenir alors regardons un tout petit
peu plus dans le détail comment les
choses se passent les porteurs vont
venir dessus pour les deux
développements les crédits augmentent un
nouveau signe effectif significativement
je l'ai dit 13% en crédit de paiement 9%
ce qui concerne le cœur de la
c'est-à-dire les dons projets on note
surtout une hausse de 146% des crédits
de gestion et sortie de crise qui passe
à 730 millions d'euros ce qui en dit
long du reste sur l'état du monde
bien évidemment vous nous direz comment
vous envisagez l'affectation de ces
crédits de gestion de crise est-ce que
cette faute est-ce que cette hausse ne
reflète pas malheureusement une sorte de
retour en arrière de l'aide au
développement à l'aide humanitaire qui
correspond à une forte dégradation de la
situation dans de nombreux pays
notamment au Sahel par ailleurs nous
aimerions évidemment avoir quelques
nouvelles de la commission d'évaluation
de la je profite pour passer ce
message parce que la loi date du 6 août
ou 4 août je sais jamais c'est 4 août
4 août
2021 et
ça fait plus d'un an que nous attendons
la mise en la mise en oeuvre de cette
commission qui était un apport
particulier du Sénat dans ce dans ce
projet et donc que nous souhaiterions
que vous nous fassiez part de vous
intentions concernant la mise en œuvre
de cette commission d'évaluation en ce
qui concerne les moyens du corps
diplomatique du réseau diplomatique
encore une fois nous nous réjouissons de
l'augmentation des effectifs
106 ETP en 2023 depuis des années
nous avons répété combien notre réseau
s'affaiblissait qui n'avait pas pu faire
face au défi lié au coronavirus
l'engagement sans faille des personnels
à cette occasion et je tiens du reste
ici au nom de la Commission à renouveler
notre reconnaissance pour les l'ensemble
des équipes diplomatiques à travers le
monde et qui ont été vraiment
extraordinairement mobilisés mais il
était plus que temps de redonner des
moyens humains au Quai d'Orsay dans ces
temps de compétition internationale
exacerbée on voit bien que des pays
bien sûr des pays voisins tel
l'Allemagne la Grande-Bretagne mais
aussi la Turquie et d'autres pays font
beaucoup d'efforts en matière de
d'intensification de leur présence
diplomatiques et donc je pense que nous
ne devons pas creuser les cartes qui
nous séparent d'eux
vous ne vous étonnerez pas que j'évoque
bien sûr l'application de la réforme de
l'encadrement de la haute fonction
publique au Quai d'Orsay les assises de
la diplomatie doivent être l'occasion de
revenir sur les conséquences de cette
réforme je rappelle que notre commission
dans un but constructif madame la
ministre a
fait un certain nombre de
recommandations à l'issue d'un très gros
travail qui a été affecté à la fois par
nos deux rapporteurs André Vallini et
Jean-Pierre Grand que je remercie je
rappelle que nos rapporteurs
soulignaient notamment un certain nombre
de points délicats et ils ont formulé un
certain propositions pour les aplanir je
pense que nous aurions peut-être enfin
le gouvernement pourrait être
avoir beaucoup à gagner à prendre
quelques unes de ces propositions nous
sommes en effet très attentif vous le
savez à la qualité de notre personnel
diplomatique qui est reconnu dans le
monde entier et une fois de plus nous
voulons redire solennellement combien il
est nécessaire de préserver cet outil au
combien précieux
autre sujet de préoccupation de notre
commission la sécurité de nos
concitoyens et de nos implantations à
l'étranger nous avons tous en tête les
images de l'attaque récent de notre
ambassade à Ouagadougou et donc vous
nous direz si vos moyens sont à la
hauteur des enjeux dans un monde où
l'affrontement n'est plus un risque mais
trop souvent une réalité ce qui rend
plus que jamais nécessaire la protection
de nos diplomates professionnelles voilà
à titre d'introduction je rappelle
madame la ministre que cette audition
fait l'objet d'une captation
audiovisuelle qu'elle est diffusée en
direction du site internet du Sénat je
vais vous donner la parole pour une
quinze ou 20 minutes si vous voulez bien
puis après nous aurons l'intervention
des différents rapporteurs et de nos
collègues qui le souhaiteront
vous avez la parole
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président Mesdames les
sénatrices mais les sénateurs je suis
très heureuse d'abord je tiens à vous le
dire de vous retrouver aujourd'hui dans
le cadre de l'examen du projet de loi de
finance pour 2023 et d'inaugurer vous
l'avez dit président un nouveau cycle
d'audition
le 2 septembre dernier lors de la
conférence des ambassadrices et des
ambassadeurs le président comment on
s'en souvient il était là j'avais
réaffirmé qu'accroître notre ambition
diplomatique en cohérence avec le
renforcement de l'ensemble des fonctions
régaliennes de l'État que nous avions vu
à l'oeuvre ces quelques dernières années
impliquer aussi d'augmenter les moyens
du ministère de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères augmentation
amorcée ces deux dernières années le
projet de budget que nous souhaitons
aujourd'hui à l'examen de votre
commission renforce cette tendance avec
une hausse des moyens du ministère qui
bénéficient tant à la mission action
extérieure de l'État qu'à notre
politique d'aide publique au
développement et le budget prévoit aussi
une hausse inédite en 30 ans j'y
reviendrai comme sur chacun de ces
points hausse donc de nos moyens humains
cette évolution prend tout son sens à la
lumière de l'environnement international
dans lequel nous vivons et que je
voudrais rappeler dans un premier temps
même si je l'ai fait de façon plus
complète ou qui s'efforçait d'être plus
complète lors de la conférence des
ambassadrices et des ambassadeurs
vous le savez nos intérêts sont partout
contestés qu'ils soient politiques ou
économique nous sommes confrontés à des
menaces qui visent nos ressortissants et
nos emprises et des menaces qui se
déploient également dans le champ du
digital dans le champ numérique les
actions hostiles se multiplient
également dans le champ informationnel
où nous sommes la cible on l'a vu là
aussi récemment d'opération de
propagande et de désinformation alors
nous devons y faire face avec d'autant
plus de détermination que cela s'inscrit
dans un monde en voie de fracturation
comme le président de la République l'a
dit lui-même devant vous même et notre
corps diplomatique un monde plus brutal
un monde où il est essentiel que la
diplomatie intervienne plus activement
la tendance ne date pas
d'hier évidemment mais elle a pris une
ampleur nouvelle et inédite depuis
quelques décennies lorsque la Russie a
fait il y a 7 mois le choix de ramener
la guerre sur le continent européen en
agressant militairement l'Ukraine
la portée de cette guerre dépasse
largement le continent européen parce
que en envahissant l'Ukraine la Russie
apportait atteinte au principe
fondamentaux de la Charte des Nations
Unies principe qui eux seuls peuvent
garantir la paix entre les nations c'est
pourquoi nous ayons à bien faire
comprendre que ce sujet concerne tous
les états de la communauté
internationale et pas seulement nos
états l'Ukraine bien évidemment le
premier chef les pays européens puisque
c'est une guerre sur le continent
européen mais ça concerne l'ensemble des
États de la communauté internationale
qui ne peuvent pas laisser bafouer les
principes premiers qui permettent une
vie entre les uns et les autres sans
trop de difficultés c'est pourquoi aussi
des mécanismes comme ceux de la Cour
pénale internationale sur le plan
multilatéral ou sur le plan européen de
la facilité européenne de paix ont
aujourd'hui plus d'importance que jamais
du fait de cette agression des
situations de tension deviennent des
situations de crise énergétiques ou
alimentaires par exemple
situation qui exacerbe les divisions au
risque d'ailleurs d'une fragmentation
durable de la scène internationale dont
on peut se demander bien sûr si elle
n'est pas l'un des objectifs de la
Russie
fragmentation entre l'Est et l'Ouest
entre le Nord et le Sud
cette fracturation
apparaît par ailleurs et c'est sans
doute le grand paradoxe de notre époque
au moment où nous avons plus que jamais
besoin de bâtir des coopérations afin
d'apporter des solutions à ce qu'on
appelle les enjeux globaux et des
solutions durables
ces enjeux ce sont multipliés ces
dernières années tout en gagnant en
complexité et en technicité aussi climat
environnement biodiversité
océan
alimentation santé ce sont autant
d'exemples que je peux prendre et autant
de domaines où la France a pris la tête
des efforts mondiaux pour protéger bien
commun ça suppose des compétences je
pose des moyens ça suppose des
ressources humaines
les moyens supplémentaires que je
m'apprête à vous présenter en vocation à
répondre à ces enjeux
il nous permettront de déployer une
diplomatie que j'ai appelé de mes vœux
comme étant une diplomatique combative
des ailes présents de la République
innovantes une diplomatie de résultats
aussi au service de nos compatriotes et
donc cette fin il est essentiel de
maintenir un outil diplomatique
universel capable de se déployer partout
dans le monde et d'agir dans la totalité
ou la quasi-totalité des organisations
régionales et internationales
la France je le rappelle dispose du
troisième réseau diplomatique mondial
fort de 163 d'ambassade de 16
représentations permanentes et de 90
consulats généraux cet universalité de
notre réseau nous permet d'être présent
partout et il le faut et nommé en mesure
de parler à tout le monde et il le faut
c'est un atout majeur vraiment je
voudrais insister sur ce point pour
bâtir les coalitions d'actions dont nous
avons besoin pour agir à l'ONU dans les
organisations internationale nous ne
sommes pas seuls nous devons pouvoir
peser sur un certain nombre de
situations et puis vous l'avez rappelé
monsieur le Président c'est aussi cet
outil universel à notre type puissant au
service de nos ressortissants dans le
monde que nous avons pu ainsi aider par
exemple partout dans le monde au moment
de la pandémie de covid 19 quand elle
était à son plus haut niveau
pour répondre à ce contexte
international inédit il fallait un
projet de budget ambitieux pour le
ministère de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères donc j'aimerais maintenant
vous en présenter l'économie générale
les rapporteurs bien sûr seront
peut-être plus précis
le budget de mon ministère quand vous
avez ce compose de deux missions
principales de missions dont le ministre
est responsable la première c'est la
mission action extérieure de l'État qui
comprend les programmes 105 actions de
la France en Europe et dans le monde
151 Français de l'étranger et à faire
consulaires et 185 diplomatiques
culturelles et d'influence et puis la
seconde mission c'est la mission aide
publique au développement qui se compose
de deux programmes le programme 110 aide
économique et financière au
développement qui est porté par le
ministère de l'économie et des finances
et le programme 209 solidarité à l'égard
des pays en développement qui relèvent
du Quai d'Orsay deux programmes
budgétaires donc 110 et 209 porté par
deux ministères mais qui constitue une
seule mission la mission être publique
au développement dont mon ministère et
le responsable
alors la trajectoire à la hausse de
notre budget se confirme et s'amplifie
en 2023
ce budget devrait atteindre en effet
six milliards 65 en crédit de paiement
pour l'ensemble des missions en
augmentation de 543 millions d'euros
soit par rapport à la loi de finance
initiale de 2022 plus 9%
. j'entre un peu dans quelques détails
structurants cette hausse bénéficiera
d'une part et à hauteur de 160 millions
d'euros supplémentaires à la mission
action extérieure de l'État la première
qui atteindra 3 milliards 218 3
milliards 218 ça constitue une
augmentation substantielle
et d'autre part cette hausse inscrit
dans le cas de l'augmentation des moyens
de la deuxième mission aide publique au
développement le programme 209 celui qui
est rattaché au Quai d'Orsay en
bénéficiera à hauteur de
383,1 millions d'euros et donc ce
programme 209 au total atteindra 3
milliards 436 si on le compare aux 3
milliards 218 la première mission vous
voyez donc que le programme est publique
au développement devient prépondérant
dans le budget du ministère
et j'ajoute puisque nous parlons d'être
public au développement que les deux
programmes cumulés de la mission APD
donc celui porté par ce ministère et
celui qui est porté par Bercy donc 209
et 110 au total
atteindront à eux de 5 milliards 77 ce
qui représente une hausse par rapport à
2022 de 17%
et je le rappelle un doublement des
crédits de l'aide publique au
développement par rapport à 2017 donc ça
a été un effort considérable fait par
notre pays sous l'impulsion notamment de
la représentation nationale que je
remercie
par ailleurs et ces particulièrement
notable cette année nous effectifs vont
croître et vont croître pour la première
fois en 30 ans puisque la dernière fois
c'était en 1993 avec 100 et TP
supplémentaire 106 en réalité monsieur
le Président si l'on compte ceux qui
sont transférés par la dièse
vous le savez nos effectifs avaient
considérablement baissé au fil des
années même au fil des décennies avec
une baisse de 30% sur les deux dernières
décennies
sans modification substantielle du
périmètre je le précise parce que il
faut que les comparaisons permettent de
comparer des choses comparables mises à
part la question des ETI experts
techniques ils sont pas si nombreux que
ça affecte le périmètre donc moins 30%
sur les deux dernières décennies et
moins 17% depuis 2006
le budget 2023 marque donc une rupture
avec cette tendance une tendance qui
n'était plus soutenable Jean-Yves Le
Drian avait parlé je crois d'hémorragie
et ceci alors que vous l'avez dit
monsieur le Président et nous le savons
tous les moyens de nos principaux
partenaires ont cru ces dernières années
parce qu'ils étaient eux-mêmes face à
une augmentation des besoins que soit
des crises ou des enjeux globaux
le plafond d'emploi du ministère est
insupporté dans le PLF 2023 à
équivalent en plein travaillé
il s'agit d'une augmentation
substantielle pour un ministère comme le
nôtre j'entends d'autres ministres
portaient des chiffres supérieurs mais
le périmètre n'est pas le même
augmentation qui visera à mieux répondre
à des besoins accrus essentiellement par
la multiplication des crises
afin de financer à la fois la hausse de
notre plafond d'emploi et la poursuite
des réformes en cours au sein du
ministère notre masse salariale
connaîtra une hausse raisonnable de 6%
par rapport à la LFI 2022
ses moyens nouveaux nous permettront
d'accélérer notre réforme des ressources
humaines au bénéfice de toutes les
catégories d'agents nous l'avons
souhaité mais c'est bien normal
titulaire contractuel et agent de droit
local
s'agissant des rémunérations
nous avons veillé à ce que les mesures
bénéficient également à toutes les
catégories d'agents après le plan RH de
2022 qui a permis notamment une
augmentation des rémunérations des
titulaires comme des contractuels en
administration centrale nous
poursuivrons en 2023 la mise en oeuvre
du plan de convergence des rémunérations
entre titulaire et contractuel en y
consacrant
six millions 6 millions 4 euros
un million six sera également consacré à
la revalorisation des volontaires
internationaux qui sont des jeunes
collègues qui font un travail très utile
remarquable même souvent dans nos
ambassades et 3 millions d'euros seront
dévolus à l'harmonisation des conditions
salariales des recrutées locaux on sait
qu'il y a des disparités salariales par
exemple entre les agents de relocal qui
sont recrutés dans une ambassade ceux
qui sont recrutés par un institut
français dont le statut juridique est
différent enfin mon ministère 20
poursuivre la mise en oeuvre de la
réforme de la haute fonction publique
qui ne touche pas que mon ministère mais
qui le touche également vous l'avez
évoqué en faisant évoluer son
organisation et son fonctionnement pour
jouer pleinement si nous le pouvons le
rôle de chef de fil interministériel de
l'action extérieure de l'État que tant
le président de la République que la
première ministre ont rappelé à
l'occasion de la conférence des
ambassadrices et des ambassadeurs et qui
est une de l'efficacité de l'État dans
son action internationale
j'ai annoncé
lundi c'était lundi en effet les
lancement des états généraux de la
diplomatie dans le présent de la
République avait bien voulu accepter
l'idée et il avait
signalé dans son discours la première
ministre aussi et donc les choses
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs sont
désormais partis à compter de la semaine
prochaine
elles sont publiques vous savez sans
doute que c'est une mission que j'ai
confié à l'ambassadeur bonafan Jérôme
bonafon qui est en poste Nations Unies
Genève enfin notre
représentant permanent que d'être le
rapporteur général de cette mission il
avait certains s'en souviennent beaucoup
travaillé sur les questions de
ressources humaines et d'adaptation de
vos enjeux au sein du ministère avec un
travail que lui avait confié mon
prédécesseur qui avait été je crois
apprécié de tous ce qui le qualifiait
tout légèrement pour mener cette
nouvelle mission l'enjeu pour nous c'est
vraiment de tracer les contours de la
diplomatie professionnelle de demain
nous tenons à ce qu'il soit bien clair
dans l'esprit de tous que il y a
une professionnalisation des essais il y
a des réflexes professionnels il y a une
expérience professionnelle qui
s'acquiert au fil des années en partant
des besoins du nouveau contexte dans
lequel nous agissons et en essayant d'y
être le plus efficace possible pour
répondre aux enjeux d'aujourd'hui et de
demain en faisant s'il le faut évoluer
aussi nos méthodes de travail puisque
nos ressources quoique en augmentation
reste limitée
après cette présentation générale des
évolutions du budget j'aimerais insister
sur quelques grands axes en me
concentrant sur quelques priorités donc
de façon qui n'est pas du tout
exhaustive bien sûr une des grandes
caractéristiques de ce projet de budget
une des grandes priorités donc c'est
l'aide humanitaire
notre capacité à répondre aux crises
humanitaire que la guerre en
Ukraine a rendu encore plus
évidente et plus grave est aujourd'hui
un enjeu majeur ce projet de budget en
prend la mesure pleinement je crois
notre aide humanitaire programmée
atteint ainsi 642 millions d'euros sur
ces trois canaux principaux 200 millions
mise en oeuvre par le fond d'urgence et
de stabilisation
qui est en augmentation de 30 millions
c'est un saut important
160 millions dédiés à l'aide alimentaire
programmée en augmentation de près de 42
millions
41,7 donc une augmentation également
importante et puis 200 millions pour les
contributions volontaires humanitaires
aux Nations Unies en augmentation de 19
millions et demi siège l'initiative farm
faut d'un agriculture
qui sera financé par la France à hauteur
de 75 millions d'euros afin de répondre
à l'aggravation de la sécurité
alimentaire je dis bien l'insécurité
alimentaire mondiale provoquée par les
conséquences de l'invasion de l'Ukraine
par la Russie un certain nombre de
blocus qui devrait prendre fin si nous
vivions dans le monde que nous espérons
afin d'être le plus réactif possible
cette programmation donc vraiment à la
hausse c'est doublé de la constitution
d'une provision pour crise majeure nous
nous étions rendu compte que les
prévisions étaient parfois vite
dépassées par la marche des temps et
l'avancée des crises et donc nous avons
réussi à presque décupler au plus que
décuplés en réalité
cette provision pour crise qui passera
de 23 millions d'euros si le PF 2023
bien sûr reçoit votre approbation à 270
millions c'est une mesure de précaution
je pense qu'elle était absolument
nécessaire c'est un saut quantitatif
mais aussi un saut qualitatif qui doit
nous permettre de répondre plus
efficacement plus rapidement à des
situations d'urgence dans le domaine
humanitaire évidemment priorité donc
potentiellement si
un additionne tout cela ce sont
912 millions d'euros qui pourraient être
consacrés à l'aide humanitaire en 2023
par mon ministère
voilà la première grande priorité une
autre grande priorité vous l'avez
évoquée aussi monsieur Briand c'est la
sécurité dans un contexte que je
décrivais très brièvement au début de ma
prise de parole de
persistance de difficultés souvent même
d'aggravation des difficultés en Afrique
on l'a vu au Burkina Faso mais pas
seulement au même en Europe les moyens
nouveaux du programme 105
concerneront puisque nous avons pu
obtenir des moyens nouveaux pour le 105
concerneront notamment la sécurisation
de nos emprises avec une enveloppe de 5
millions d'euros en plus en autorisation
d'engagement et de trois en crédit de
paiement de façon notamment à renforcer
la sécurité de quelques postes
diplomatiques qu'il fallait d'évidence
renforcer Islamabad on se souvient que
du temps du gouvernement Pakistan et
précédent il y avait des manifestations
assez importantes devant notre ambassade
de Bagdad qui reste un pays où la
stabilité n'est pas assurée ou Dadis
Abeba qui reste aussi en crise et puis
plus généralement qui permettra de
sécuriser nos ambassades là où nos
agences sont exposés à des situations de
crise ou d'instabilité vous évoquez
monsieur le Président wagadougou l'une
des premières décisions que j'ai prises
et de demander et de faire envoyer un
renfort de quelques unités de gendarmes
pour renforcer la sécurité
habituelle de l'ambassade
autre priorité
et servi mieux que l'année précédente
par l'augmentation des crédits du 105 le
numérique nous avons depuis quelques
années une politique d'investissement
soutenu qui était qui était bien
nécessaire mais nous devons encore
améliorer l'efficacité de nos outils
pallier quelques inégalités de
déploiement qui demeure selon les pays
et puis d'une façon générale renforcée
la cybersécurité de notre réseau réseau
dont je rappelle qu'il est le deuxième
plus attaqué de France après celui de la
présidence de la République donc nous
poursuivrons cette stratégie
d'investissement numérique en 2023 et
les moyens de la direction compétent et
que sa direction du numérique dénume
s'établiront à 52,2 millions d'euros en
augmentation de 4 millions 4 rapportés à
la base 2022 c'est une belle
augmentation aussi
autre priorité
permise par l'augmentation des moyens
pour 2023 tels que le projet de budget
vous le présente c'est la communication
stratégique là aussi en jeu de plus en
plus pressant nous sommes confrontés à
des
manœuvres des manipulations de
l'information des désinformations de la
propagande aussi souvent d'origine russe
même si nous sommes en captation vidéo
je peux le dire et qui vise pas que mais
qui vise à souvent en tout cas de la
part de la Russie agir pour attiser des
discours anti-français sur les réseaux
sociaux notamment en Afrique dans
quelques pays européens également et
nous l'avons vu évidemment leur du coup
d'État au Burkina Faso alors afin de
mieux lutter contre ces pratiques mais
pas dans l'état le seul
qu'ici emploi nous augmenterons de 2
millions et demi les moyens de la
direction de la communication et de la
presse avec 2 millions et demi avec une
sous-direction nouvelle qui sera chargée
pour ce qui concerne le Quai d'Orsay
d'autres
d'autres entités s'en occupent également
dans l'état de contrer de faire plus de
veille et de contrer ces opérations de
désinformation et puis dernière priorité
sur laquelle nous avons réparti les
quelques millions d'euros dans nos
disposions
l'éducation en français et à la
française nous avons
566 établissements dans 138 pays
pratiquement l'ensemble des pays du
monde à cette une force un outil
remarquable il faut poursuivre il faut
s'en servir nos scolarisons presque 400
000 élèves 390 000 et nous avons
le plan de développement
horizon 2030 qu'il faut poursuivre donc
nous renforçons les moyens de la fe à
hauteur de 30 millions d'euros
quatrième et dernier point c'est
priorités thématiques
s'accompagneront d'une préoccupation
constante qui est d'aider et de protéger
les Français à l'étranger ou les
Français de passage à l'étranger
comme chacun a pu le constater lors de
la pandémie le Quai d'Orsay est aussi le
service public des Français à l'étranger
en 2023 notre action consulaire donc le
programme 151 sera doté de
141,1 million d'euros or dépenses du
personnel
avec une baisse apparente de 900
millions d'euros en crédit de paiement
par rapport à 2022 et 2022 qui était une
année électorale avec un coût de
l'organisation des élections
présidentielles et législative qui
s'était élevé à 13,5 millions d'euros
donc ils ne sont pas nécessaires en 2023
somme qu'il est donc
inutile de budgéter au budget 2023
au total cette évolution donc notamment
en rien la qualité du service que nous
offrons à nos compatriotes puisque nous
avons aussi pu compenser avec une hausse
décrédies budgétaires octroyés aux
Français de l'étranger et élections
consulaire de plus
12,6 millions d'euros en 2023
alors que nos compatriotes sont
confrontés dans de nombreux pays des
contextes économiques dégradés ont
souvent besoin de plus d'aide de plus
d'aide sociale notamment ils pourront
continuer de compter sur celle-ci
je redis que nous offrons en service
consulaire un service coquin d'autres
pays au monde n'offre à ces concitoyens
et c'est une fierté que la France doit
avoir les bourses scolaires destinées
aux enfants français de nos
établissements scolaires retrouveront
leur niveau de 2021 avec un budget de
105,8 millions d'euros qui comprend par
ailleurs des bourses spécifiques
maintenant pour les enfants en situation
de handicap
afin de répondre aux besoinscru de la
Communauté française à l'étranger
lorsqu'il y a eu des contextes
économiques plus difficiles
des crédits supplémentaires seront
alloués au titre de l'aide sociale je
l'évoquais 16 millions 2 en 2023 soit 1
million d'augmentation par rapport à
la location SOS covid
12 millions de rangs 2021 4 millions 3
en 2022 sera remplacé pour ceux de nos
compatriotes qui en aurait besoin par
une aide sociale classique
ils pourront aussi compter sur le
soutien des organismes locaux d'entraide
et solidarités que nous aidons à hauteur
de 1 million quatre en 2023 mais aussi
de celle des associations porteuses de
projets bénéficiant aux Français
d'étrangers grâce aux dispositif du
staff avec 2 millions 2023
toutes ces aides qui sont et seront
distribués en lien avec les élus
consulaires qui constituent un précieux
relais des besoins des Français de
l'étranger je l'ai constaté moi-même
dans mes différents postes et donc sont
bien utiles l'efficacité de nos actions
être aux côtés des Français de
l'étranger
c'est aussi faciliter leur vie en
facilitant leur démarche et en ce sens
nous en prie la décision de poursuivre
la modernisation de notre action
consulaire à travers trois projets
phares la numérisation du registre de
l'état civil
l'amélioration continue du dispositif de
vote par internet pour mémoire 75%
environ des votes des Français à
l'étranger cet effet cette année par
internet donc il faut se servir de ce
dispositif qui permet une meilleure
participation de nos compatriotes et
enfin troisièmement par la
l'extension de l'expérimentation du
service France consulaire qui s'est
révélé particulièrement
utile
dans les 13 pays où nous avons pu le
déployer depuis sa création en octobre
dernier donc il y a juste un nom Croatie
Danemark Hongrie Irlande Lettonie
Lituanie Malte Moldavie
Norvège République tchèque Roumanie
Slovénie et suède et donc nous
continuerons d'étendre ce service en
Europe en 2023 avec la Bulgarie et
Chypre ou encore la graisse voilà puis
dans le reste du monde au fur et à
mesure des moyens disponibles
et des les Français de l'étranger enfin
c'est développer de nouveaux services
comme l'expérimentation du
renouvellement des passeports
renouvellement première
démarche qui sera possible sans
comparution par une expérimentation qui
débutera l'an prochain au Canada et au
Portugal ou encore
autre exemple d'amélioration le
déploiement à grande échelle de la
nouvelle application de rendez-vous
consulaire qui était je crois bien
attendu par nos consulats tout autant
que par nos compatriotes voilà monsieur
le Président Mesdames laissées natrices
monsieur les sénateurs quelques-unes des
avancées permissent par ce projet de loi
de finance 2023 que je souhaitais porter
à votre attention hausse de nos
effectifs la première même c'est les
modestes la première depuis trois
décennies augmentation sensible de nos
moyens budgétaires avec des priorités
clairement définies
clairement assumé poursuit du
renforcement notre aide publique au
développement et donc
aussi avec l'accent que j'ai souhaité
sur notre capacités d'action
humanitaires et puis un service public
pour nos compatriotes établis à
l'étranger votre passage avec en
particulier cette action mis sur les
plus fragiles grâce à l'augmentation de
l'aide sociale donc un budget je crois
qu'il reflète
des fortes attentes à l'égard de notre
diplomatie mais en fait aussi la
confiance qu'avec ce projet de budget le
présent de la République et la première
mise et mon collègue du budget ont bien
voulu témoigner un autre appareil
diplomatique c'est aussi je crois un
hommage qu'il rende à tous nos
diplomates alors sens de l'État et de
l'intérêt général et l'engagement dont
ils font preuve en Ukraine et ailleurs
jour après jour
quand je dis ailleurs c'est en France
aussi ne l'oublions pas je suis à votre
disposition pour répondre à des
questions sur ce projet de loi de
finances 2023 ou quelques autres que
vous voudriez me poser merci Madame la
Ministre merci d'avoir bien voulu
confirmer ces bonnes nouvelles
que nous attendions depuis longtemps
notamment le renforcement des moyens sur
l'action extérieure de l'État et donc
sans plus attendre je vais donner la
parole tout d'abord au rapporteur auquel
vous répondrez puis après j'aurai une
liste de questions minutes de
liste importante de nos collègues donc
au titre du programme 105 action de la
France en Europe et dans le monde vous
savez que la tradition la tradition ici
c'est de donner d'avoir toujours deux
rapporteurs l'un représentant la
majorité et l'autre l'opposition encore
que c'est un travail commun auquel je
remage en l'occurrence ça ne commencera
pas par deux intervenants puisque notre
collègue André gatelin donne une
conférence à Rome c'est le jour de
l'audience c'est donc je donne tout de
suite la parole à Jean-Pierre Grand qui
parlera au nom des deux rapporteurs
parce que je serai obligé de partir pour
des raisons d'avion donc voilà
donc tout d'abord il est il est tout à
fait naturel de rendre hommage appuyé au
personnel du ministère qui incarne un
service public cela a été dit il faut le
redire
aux Français révélés au grand public par
la crise sanitaire naturellement mais
aussi c'est comme tous les esprits
l'évacuation de Kaboul
ressortissant à cagoule parce que sa
bière ça ancrée c'est ancré dans dans la
mémoire de nos compatriotes l'arrêt des
l'arrêt des déflation l'année dernière
était indispensable après la perte de
3000 postes depuis 2007 on ne peut donc
se féliciter président comme bon la
exprimé clairement de la création cette
année de 100 post pour répondre aux
besoins prioritaires de diplomatie cela
permettra de renforcer le renforcement
de notre présence dans l'Indopacifique
et notre capacité d'analyse politique
dans certains pays cela permettra
également d'améliorer notre
cybersécurité et la sécurisation de nos
emprises j'aurais l'occasion d'y revenir
les ressources humaines sont la richesse
de votre ministère et je me réjouis que
les nouveaux recrutements puissent venir
soulager les postes les postes ou les
poster ou la charge de travail qui était
devenue bien trop pesant
particulièrement pour les secrétaires
généraux d'ambassade le projet de loi de
finance prévoit-il bien des mesures
nécessaires pour faire face à
l'inflation et accompagner l'évolution
nécessaire les contrats de droit locaux
c'est notre première question sur la
politique immobilière dès 2015 notre
commission recommandée deux axes
essentiels pour votre ministère
premièrement l'établissement d'un schéma
pluriel de stratégie immobilière pour
l'ensemble du patrimoine immobilier du
ministère il a été présenté en novembre
2021 et s'appuie sur les recommandations
de notre commission deuxièmement
l'inscription des crédits nécessaires à
l'entretien de ce patrimoine à loi de
finances initiale pour l'année 2023 je
crois pouvoir délivrer au nom de notre
commission satisfaitie
sur ce sujet le programme 105 est
désormais doté de crédit à la hauteur
des besoins
jusqu'à 80 millions et 90 et 80 millions
ce qui est très précisément le montant
que nous recommandons
janvier à la sécurisation de nos
emprises à l'étranger vous l'avez abordé
madame madame la ministre tout d'abord
je veux assurer des personnels qui ont
subi les attaques dans l'ambassade à au
Burkina de notre soutien sans faille
l'enjeu de sécurité ne peut pas être
ignoré
et vous n'ignorez pas naturellement
les travaux dans cette réaliser au plus
vite et financer et financer alors il
était prévu que la sécurisation nous
emprise à l'étranger soit financée par
29 ventes permettant de rembourser
l'avance du compte d'affectation
spéciale de 100 millions d'euros en
commission c'était pas c'était pas une
perspective qui réjouissait notre
commission bien loin de là donc je vous
redis que pour nous c'est pas c'est pas
c'est pas raisonnable pouvez nous
assurer pouvez-vous nous assurer que
nous retrouverons pas devant avec des
personnels qui ne se logent plus ou qui
louent et ainsi avec un calcul rapide ce
qui a été vendu le bénéfice de ce qui
est vendu serait perdu en 10 heures en
dix années en dix années enfin comme l'a
dit le Président mon collègue ne pouvant
nous pouvons être là en règle me demande
de charges de vos de vous faire part de
sa satisfaction cette année encore pour
l'effort réalisé en matière de
contribution volontaire en 2023 à la
France prévoit de RC 58,3 millions de
contributions volontaires sur le 105
pouvez nous en donner le détail le
décrochage de la parité euro-dollar et
l'envolée de l'inflation ont-ils bien
été pris en compte la fixation de ce
montant
c'est aussi bien sûr partagé par le
président il a dit tout à l'heure mais
aussi par l'ensemble de la commission
êtes-vous en mesure de nous présenter
les retombées de cette politique
volontarisme menée depuis quelques
années
la France est-elle parvenue à peser sur
les orientations et les décisions de
certaines des fonds qu'elle aborde ainsi
de façon volontaire voilà mes questions
merci au titre du 185 diplomaties
culturelles et d'influence Renan legleux
tout d'abord puis André Vallini merci
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
le projet de loi de finances prévoit une
augmentation de la subvention versée à
l'EFE à hauteur de 30 millions d'euros
en 2023 afin notamment de financer la
moitié des surcoûts liés à la réforme
des statuts des personnels détachés
alors l'autre moitié de ce surcoût
estimé à 7 millions d'euros sera-t-elle
financé sur la trésorerie de l'agence
déjà mise à contribution à hauteur de 20
millions d'euros l'an dernier pour le
financement des aides à la scolarité de
l'aide en faveur du Liban
pourriez-vous également nous indiquer où
en sont les discussions concernant la
hausse de la cotisation retraite qui
devait passer de 11,10% à
27,77% des fonctionnaires détachés à
l'étranger prévues par un décret du 26
avril 2002 et abrogé par décret dès le 2
juin par ailleurs lors de son discours
du 20 mars 2018 à l'Institut de France
sur l'ambition pour la langue française
et le plurilinguisme le président de la
République a fixé l'objectif de doubler
les effectifs de l'enseignement français
à l'étranger c'est-à-dire d'accueillir
700 000 élèves à l'horizon 2030 or au
rythme actuel de croissance des
effectifs le doublement n'interviendrait
qu'après 2050 madame la ministre ma
question est donc simple pensez-vous
sincèrement être en mesure d'atteindre
cet objectif dans les délais fixés par
le Président de la République enfin ma
dernière question dépasse le champ du
programme 185 strictosensus et porte sur
l'accès des lycéens français de
l'étranger aux formations du supérieur
en France selon un article du Monde
ceux-ci sont en effet souvent évincés
par parcoursup les statistiques
mentionnées dans cet article sont
révélatrices le 27 mai 2021 seul 20% des
25000 lycéens français à l'étranger
avaient reçu une proposition d'admission
contre 54 % des autres lycéens le 16
juillet 2021 au moment de la fin de la
face principale d'admission 48% des
lycéens français à l'étranger avec reçu
une réponse positive contre 89% des
lycéens français scolarisés sur le
territoire national ou dans le réseau de
l'AEFE pourriez-vous donc nous indiquer
si des actions qui étaient prises par
votre ministère en lien avec les
ministères de l'Éducation nationale et
de l'enseignement supérieur pour
remédier à cette situation je vous
remercie madame la ministre
André Vallini oui monsieur le Président
je souhaite avant de parler du budget et
en quelques mots très rapides évoqué le
processus diplomatique en cours visant à
encadrer l'usage d'armes explosives à
large rayon d'impact en zone peuplée je
suis de près ce processus avec certains
de d'entre vous mes chers collègues le
président de camban va demander
d'organiser une réunion au nom de la
commission sur ce sujet en lien avec
Handicap International et la signature
définitive du protocole aura lieu le 18
novembre prochain à Dublin alors la
France pendant longtemps n'a pas été
très allant sur ce sujet je l'avais
évoqué à plusieurs reprises avec votre
prédécesseur madame la ministre et
depuis quelques semaines l'évolution de
la pollution française a été très très
notable et je tenais à vous en donner
acte
alors sur le budget maintenant en
décembre dernier votre prédécesseur
toujours fille Jean-Yves Le Drian avait
présenté une feuille de route de
l'influence dans les résultats devaient
figurer dans un tableau de bord la
question d'assurance est-ce qu'il a été
mis en place ce tableau de bord est si
oui quels enseignements peut-on d'ores
et des gens tirer deuxième question de
même que le doublement des effectifs
d'élèves des établissements français à
l'étranger d'ici 2030 nous sommes
difficilement atteignables Ronan Leleux
viennent en parler nous nous
interrogeons sur l'objectif d'accueillir
500 000 étudiants étrangers à l'horizon
2027 aujourd'hui la France accueille 365
000 étudiants étrangers passés à 500 000
en 4 ans nous paraît difficilement
réalisable on voudrait avoir votre
sentiment sur cet objectif troisième
question le plan bienvenue en France
lancé en 2019 était destiné à tirer
davantage d'étudiants étrangers en
France un fonds d'amorçage de 10
millions d'euros avait été mis en place
lors de son lancement
afin de soutenir les initiatives des
établissements or il est pas prévu que
ce plan soit pérennisé la question est
la suivante est-ce que certains
établissements ont été contraints
d'abandonner des actions qu'ils avaient
mises en œuvre ou dissuader d'intégrer
ce dispositif faute de financement en
fin dernière question sur la compétence
tourisme en 2012 le tourisme avait été
rattaché à titre personnel j'ai toujours
trouvé ça assez
saugrenu bon donc le tourisme revient au
ministère de l'Économie depuis le
dernier depuis la nomination du nouveau
gouvernement ce qui fait que les crédits
consacrés à Atout France 29 millions
d'euros par du programme 185 vers le
programme 134 on en prend acte est-ce
que vous pouvez nous indiquer quelles
raisons motiver ce retour que je trouve
tout à fait favorable au ministère de
l'économie de la compétence tourisme
merci André on va passer au 151 français
à l'étranger à faire consulaire bruno
Sido puis Guillaume gantard merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
depuis comme vous l'avez dit d'ailleurs
tout à l'heure depuis octobre 2021
certains de nos compatriotes résidant à
l'étranger ont accès au service France
consulaire ce service leur permet
d'obtenir des informations d'ordre
général ou d'initier une démarche
administrative sur Internet ou au
téléphone alors que ce service c'est
désormais accessible dans 13 pays
européens vous l'avez dit il ne faudrait
pas que le déploiement de cette
plateforme dématérialisée servent de
prétexte pour abandonner les points
d'accueil physique dans nos ambassades
et consulats en effet il est essentiel
que la possibilité d'être accueilli
physiquement soit maintenue en
particulier pour nos compatriotes
résidant à l'étranger les plus fragiles
nous saluons les services rendus par
cette nouvelle solution dématérialisée
dont nous sommes pleinement conscients
toutefois pouvez-vous nous confirmer ici
que le dép de ce service externalisé
n'aura pas pour conséquence une
réduction des personnels dans le service
consulaires ces derniers doivent rester
les interlocuteurs privilégiés de nos
compatriotes à l'étranger dont ils
connaissent la situation et les besoins
merci Guillaume Gontard oui merci
monsieur le Président Madame madame la
ministre donc pour la suite du programme
151 le 31 août dernier votre ministère a
supprimé le dispositif du secours
occasionnel de solidarité ou appelé SOS
covid qui avait permis de financer une
aide sociale pour environ 10000 Français
de l'étranger depuis 2020 alors qu'en
France les campagnes successives de
vaccination se sont traduites par un
recul de l'épidémie qui reste néanmoins
à confirmer la crise sanitaire continue
à se faire ressentir dans de nombreuses
régions du monde sous le continent
africain de vaccination reste par
exemple inférieur à 30% de la population
dans ce contexte c'est alors que nous
observons une reprise historique de
l'inflation dans le monde le financement
des aides sociales à destination des
Français d'étrangers connaît une
trajectoire décroissante alors que la
suppression du dispositif espèce covid
représente une réduction annuelle de
plus de 10 millions d'euros d'aide
sociale
envisagez-vous la création de nouveaux
dispositifs pour répondre à la
fragilisation de nos compatriotes
exposés de crises économiques et
sanitaires dans de nombreux pays du
monde merci
merci nous allons passer à la mission
est publique au développement avec Hulk
sorry puis Rachid themal merci monsieur
le président madame la ministre mes
chers collègues le président Cambon vous
a interrogé tout à l'heure sur les
grandes lignes de l'aide publique au
développement dans ce budget je vous
remercie d'en avoir donné les chiffres
essentiels en tant que rapporteur avec
mon collègue Rachid themal en face de
moi de ses budgets je ne peux que me
réjouir de l'évolution constante depuis
2017 je me félicite également de la
progression des montants en lien avec la
dans ce projet de loi de finance 2023
le contexte international appelle la
mobilisation de nos aides mais à
contrario le contexte national appelle
plutôt ainsi plutôt à l'économie donc
les formes n'en est que plus louable
j'ai pour ma part quelques questions sur
des points plus spécifiques le Burkina
Faso a connu un deuxième coup d'État en
moins d'un an suivant ainsi le même
chemin que son voisin malien
or l'Agence Régionale Sahel de la FD se
trouve précisément à Ouagadougou
peut-elle continuer à y travailler par
ailleurs la France venait d'annoncer le
26 septembre donc il y a très peu de
temps une aide budgétaire de 15 millions
d'euros pour le Burkina Faso quand
sera-t-il désormais
en application de la loi du 4 août 2021
le gouvernement a remis un rapport sur
la comptabilisation de l'aide publique
au développement dans celui-ci on y
apprend notamment que selon les critères
de l'OCDE les frais décollage qui
représentent une partie significative de
notre APD ne devrait être comptabilisé
que si je cite la présence des étudiants
résulte de la mise en oeuvre d'une
politique de coopération au
développement par le pays haute c'est à
dire que les autorités responsables des
programmes d'APD doivent être impliqués
dans la spécification des secteurs et
des niveaux d'éducation concernés dont
le nombre et la sélection des catégories
d'étudiants invités dans l'indaptation
des frais de scolarité aux besoins des
étudiants etc et donc ceci m'incite à
vous poser une question une telle
coordination entre votre ministère et
celui de l'enseignement supérieur
existe-t-elle aujourd'hui je vous
remercie
merci merci président merci Madame Miss
d'abord pour la présentation de tous ces
données j'ai trois questions la première
concerne la taxe sur les transactions
financières ça va être l'objet de long
discussions avec votre prédécesseur dans
le cadre de loi du 4 août 2021 d'un
accord et en échange de l'accord entre
guillemets il y avait un rapport qui
doit être mis je passe sur le fait qu'il
a fallu près du mois de retard pour le
récupérer et que ce rapport pour autant
n'aimait pas vraiment de de piste
sérieuse et en tout cas et bien en deçà
des avions eu à l'époque donc ma
question est
entendez-vous ou non faire évoluer la
part de la taxe sur les transformations
financière qui vient abonder l'aide plus
complètement ça c'est ma première
question la seconde concerne la
gouvernance même de la politique
française de solidarité internationale
puisque
il y a deux instances de pilotage d'une
part le Conseil de Développement d'autre
part le comité intermittel de la
coopération internationale et de le
vendre aussi Side et quand on discute
avec les uns les autres et on le voit
bien c'est le site qu'il y a on va dire
la prédominance sauf que ce cet
instant-là n'a pas été réuni depuis 2018
et que la loi prévoit soit tous les ans
donc ma question c'est quand sera-t-il
réuni est-ce que nous aurions est-ce que
nous aurons pardon un échange
préalablement avec le Parlement ceci est
ma seconde question la troisième
concerne la programmation financière
qu'il a aussi a fait l'objet de beaucoup
beaucoup de discussions au moment de la
loi le Parlement est su trouver des
propositions je crois utiles pour chacun
il était prévu pour autant qu'en 2022
nous puissions revoir la trajectoire
pour les années 2023 2025 or nous sommes
à quelques allez de moi de la fin de
l'année donc est-ce que là nous aurons à
nouveau une discussion
concernant cette cette revoyure cette
cause de voyage j'ai envie de dire et
puis aussi sur l'AFD là précise que nous
allons pouvoir examer rapidement le
contrat de logistique moyen puisque tout
cela bien sûr fonctionne ensemble et
puis j'en terminerai par est-il prévu
une prochaine loi de programmation même
si c'est en 2025 je me permets de le
dire parce que comme la dernière est
arrivée 3 ans après la fin du précédent
du présentoir voilà donc la question
c'est ce qu'on va assez rapidement
travailler sur une prochaine loi de
programmation merci
voilà un certain nombre de questions
d'interrogations de
de nous rapporteurs j'y joint la
question que je vous ai posé sur la
réunion de la commission d'évaluation
je vous donne la parole pour répondre
madame
merci monsieur le Président merci
aux différents rapporteurs qui ont fait
part de leurs interrogations sur
quelques points précis du budget je
m'apprêtais monsieur le Président à
répondre en effet à votre question
préalable sur la commission d'évaluation
de la BD le décret relative au modalités
de fonctionnement de cette commission
d'évaluation a été publiée il était
publiée de 6 mai dernier donc 6 mai 2022
et mon ministère ainsi que la direction
générale du Trésor travaille en ce
moment avec la Cour des comptes afin que
ces travaux puissent débuter au plus
tard au début de l'année prochaine selon
le mécanisme que je voudrais très
brièvement décrire après figurateur sera
nommé très prochainement par la Cour des
comptes pour assurer la mise en place
effective de cette nouvelle instance une
liste de personnalités a été élaborée
conjointement avec la déjeté et il
reviendra aux membres du Parlement de
nommer les membres
[Musique]
approche assez vite
monsieur le rapporteur grand
vous m'avez posé plusieurs questions
la première sur la prise en compte de
l'inflation dans quelle mesure
l'inflation était présente notamment
pour l'évolution des contrats de droits
locaux le PLF 2023 inclut bien une
provision d'inflation d'un montant de 24
millions d'euros pour l'ensemble des
programmes qui supportent des dépenses
de personnel et donc susceptibles d'être
affecté à ce titre provision qui
concerne nos agents titulaires ou
contractuels à l'étranger et qui inclut
un montant en faveur des agents de droit
local en tant de 3 millions d'euros
qui donc pourront bénéficier un gendre
local également dans rattrapage
d'inflation et le montant des crédits
provisionnés et basé comme il se doit
sur les prévisions du Fond Monétaire
International pays par pays
votre autre question portée sur le les
enjeux de sécurité leur mode de
financement je voudrais rappeler qu'en
2017 et 2018 les ressources du compte
d'affectation spéciale
non pas été sollicité pour le plan de
remise à niveau de nos ambassade ces
deux années donc 2017-2018 ont été
intégralement financés sur le brame 105
ensuite pour 2019 et 2020 un droit
d'accès au crédit du casse donc le 723 a
été ouvert pour un montant de 67
milliards d'euros 64 pour la Direction
de la Sécurité diplomatique de mon
ministère et 3 millions pour la EFE
un accord était conclu en 2018 entre les
ministres qui permettait que 50% du
produit Sécession soit directement
consacré au remboursement de l'avance
donc ce plan de sécurisation c'est
poursuivi à ce jour sur les 64 millions
d'euros 60 ont été engagés donc hors
périmètre AEFE et
ceci pour plusieurs réalisations qui ont
été achevées je vais citer le Burkina
Faso Djibouti le Liban la Côte d'Ivoire
l'Irak la Mauritanie le Niger la
guinéquatoriale
Oman Djibouti la RDC le Tchad l'Afrique
du Sud pour la résidence et Pékin par
ailleurs et c'est en effet plus pérenne
sans doute le ministère s'est engagé
depuis 2021 dans une rue budgétisation
des crédits d'investissement de sécurité
sur le programme 105 donc en faisant
augmenter progressivement les crédit
nous sommes passés de 13 millions
d'euros de 2020 a maintenant une
proposition pour le PLF 23 de 21
millions d'euros
dans le projet de budget qui vous est
soumis donc pour la sécurisation des
ambassades
une partie
une partie des 100 et TP supplémentaires
mais une toute petite partie parce que
nous n'allons pas répartir dans 163
ambassades sont et P sont ni pour la
sécurité ni pour les secrétariat
généraux l'ambassade mais une petite
partie des eutp supplémentaires obtenus
pour 20-23 Iran à l'accroissement des
effectifs consacrés à la sécurité de
quelques postes votre troisième question
portée sur les contributions
volontaires du programme 105 une
programmation
détaillée des contributions volontaires
ne sera finalisée qu'en début d'année
donc je ne veux pas vous répondre pour
le moment nous définissons les secteurs
clés mais seront tout à fait
classiquement le renforcement des outils
de maintien de la paix
l'approfondissement de notre soutien aux
organisations actives dans dans le champ
de la sécurité internationale je pense
notamment évidemment maintenant là
le placement de personnel en jeunes
experts associés et le renforcement de
l'attractivité du territoire français
pour les organisations internationales
où nous avions pu ces dernières années
marquer un certain nombre de
points de retomber économique bien sûr
derrière les les gains d'influence qui
nous intéressent tous le décrochage de
la parité euro-dollar et l'envolée de
l'inflation bien été prise en compte
dans la fixation de ce montant nous
payons pour mémoire l'intégralité de nos
contributions volontaires en euros
contrairement aux contributions
obligatoires qui le plus souvent se font
en dollar à l'exception de la
contribution volontaire pour les jeunes
experts associés dont je venais de
parler qui elle est réglée en dollars
américains
le sénateur le glu nous a parlé de
l'objectif de doublement du nombre
d'élèves en 20 à l'horizon 2030 je
l'évoquais
brièvement nous avons eu monsieur le
sénateur deux années de pandémie qui ont
réellement approfondément affecté le
rythme de progression tel qu'il avait
été imaginé avant que survienne la
pandémie néanmoins en 2022 nous ont pu
reprendre une trajectoire à la hausse
avec 10 000 élèves scolarisés en plus et
17 établissements créés ce qui porte le
nombre d'établissements créés depuis le
lancement de ce plan à 71 donc 71
établissements créés depuis 2018
nous espérons donc pouvoir rattraper le
retard qu'avait été pris et tenir
l'objectif
2030 vous m'avez interrogé sur
parcoursup
les élèves du réseau de la fe ont
vocation à rejoindre l'enseignement
supérieur français c'est tout à fait
vrai qu'il s'agisse d'ailleurs des
élèves français scolarisés dans le
réseau ou des
de ceux qui ne le sont pas
cela fait partie de nos axes de
promotion de l'enseignement supérieur de
la France parcoursup le point d'entrée
pour l'ensemble des élèves
indépendamment
des difficultés techniques qui peuvent
survenir elle est arrivée que certaines
difficultés soit observées c'est
vraiment
un plus grand enjeu au-delà de ces
problèmes techniques et c'est vraiment
l'enjeu de la valorisation de notre
réseau de la fe auprès des
établissements d'enseignements
supérieurs qui souvent méconnaissent nos
établissements elle ne donne pas la
priorité à ces candidatures donc il y a
des problèmes techniques dont on
souhaite qu'il soit le moins nombreux
possible d'être dans un Sud qu'il soit
résolu mais aussi un travail de
conviction à renforcer parce qu'on voit
que ça nous a pénalisés et je partage
avec vous évidemment le souhait que les
choses s'améliorent là où il le faut et
que les élèves qui ont commencé leur
parcours dans le personnes
d'enseignement français à la française
puisse rester scolarisé en France vous
vous êtes interrogé monsieur le sénateur
également sur la trésorerie de la EFE
elle a été augmentée elle a été
augmentée par l'ouverture de crédit
en PLF 3 2020 avec 50 millions d'euros
pour les bourses scolaires 50 millions
d'euros de soutien au réseau et les 50
millions d'euros qui avaient été
préoccupé 2020 pour les bourses
scolaires non pas été totalement
consommée il en reste 30 millions
d'euros qui ont été utilisés
partiellement par le PLF 2022 donc pour
20 millions d'euros sur 30 il reste donc
10 millions d'euros qui permettront
d'absorber les 7 millions d'euros de
l'évolution du statut de résidente 10
pour 7 ça va nous sommes et restons très
vigilants sur la situation de la
trésorerie de la EFE il faut pas
évidemment mettre la soutenabilité cette
opérateur en danger mais pour le moment
les choses vont bien et
le solde qui restait nous permet de
faire face aux besoins
monsieur secteur valini je répondrai
brièvement aux questions que vous avez
posées d'abord le tableau de bord a-t-il
été mis en place pour la feuille de
route influence une première ébauche de
ce tableau de bord a été réalisé au
début de l'année 2020
début de mise en place mais qui a permis
de faire la synthèse d'un certain nombre
de données et d'ores et déjà dans un
certain nombre d'enseignements
nous avons
en 2022 des projets qui ont été
définis et mis en oeuvre dans le cadre
de la mise en feuille de route
d'influence 2022 promotion de la langue
française et développement de
l'enseignement du France à l'étranger je
viens brièvement d'en parler mais j'en
avais parlé dans mon propos liminaire
promotion de l'influence culturelle et
intellectuelle avec
notamment vaucus sur l'exportation des
industries culturelles et créatives des
ICC de notre pays mais aussi je crois
que c'était bien relayé par le
développement de projet de résidence
d'artistes le premier d'entre eux en
visibilité en tout cas et dans la villa
Albertine qui permet d'attirer aussi des
donateurs et puis troisième axe le
renforcement de la politique
d'attractivité universitaire et
scientifique en lien avec la stratégie
bienvenue en France enfin la
transformation
diplomatique du réseau qu'il faut
poursuivre
là comme ailleurs vous vous étiez
interrogé sur l'objectif
[Musique]
ils sont réalisme de 500 000 étudiants
étrangers à horizon 2027
les objectifs de la stratégie bienvenue
en France
vise en effet l'accueil de 500 000
étudiants internationaux en France en
2027 ils sont 400 000 actuellement sur
notre sol donc un peu plus que le
chiffre que vous avez donné cette
stratégie a été raffermir dans la
feuille de route de l'influence que j'ai
pu développer il y a quelques semaines
maintenant quelques mois pour atteindre
l'objectif de 500 000 étudiants à
l'horizon 2027 tout proche en effet
il faut prendre une série de mesures qui
forment la substance de notre politique
d'attractivité étudiante amélioration de
la chaîne d'accueil dont le renforcement
de la formation en français langue
étrangère mais aussi le renforcement ici
des filières d'enseignement en anglais
la mise en place de frais d'inscriptions
différenciés pour les étudiants
extra-européens l'augmentation des
bourses qui se traduit en budget 2022 ça
a été fait en proposition 2023
après une baisse en 2021 nous sommes
repartis à la hausse et puis je crois
qu'il faut poursuivre un effort de
communication majeur sur notre offre de
formation qui reste trop souvent méconnu
s'appuyer notamment on commence à le
faire sur notre réseau d'adonial
ce qui connaissent notre système en ont
généralement un bon souvenir et sont de
bons ambassadeurs
le plan bienvenu
en France lancé en
19 si je me souviens bien à bourre
ambition d'être l'un de ces facteurs
d'attractivité de diversifier la
mobilité
étudiante beaucoup d'efforts ont été
déployés depuis 2021 de façon concrète
avec la mise en place notamment la
plateforme es-tu en France mais je
pourrais citer d'autres exemples et
moyens budgétaires renforcés aux zones
prioritaires géographiquement ont été
renforcés on a également augmenté le
nombre d'établissements labellisés
bienvenue en France 138 établissements
labellisés à ce jour
et ces efforts seront poursuivis il le
faut en 2023 je crois qu'il faut
poursuivre notamment en termes de
communication je l'ai dit en terme de
simplification avec une augmentation
qui avait été enregistrée des premières
campagnes donc sur 2020
de 20% de 13% pour la campagne suivante
et de 17% pour la campagne
2021-2022
je complète en disant que le ministère
de l'Enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche
en complément de ce que fait le mystère
de l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères à
mis en place un financement fléché de 10
millions d'euros pour aider au
financement de la stratégie bienvenue en
France qui est un fond d'amorçage aux
établissements
consommables donc des la fin de l'année
vous vous êtes interrogé sur le
transfert de la compétence je crois
tourisme
je ne commande pas les décrets
d'attributions qui s'imposent à nous
tous mais je dois vous faire observer
que pour la partie
attractivité du plan de reconquête et de
transformation du tourisme qui avait été
l'une des actions de cette stratégie
tourisme cette partie attractivité
demeure au ministère de l'Europe et des
Affaires étrangères avec près de 6
millions d'euros en réalité sur les 12
et demi que représentées l'action
tourisme donc presque presque une moitié
monsieur sénateur sido sur France
consulaire je serai plus rapide parce
que la réponse est simple non il n'y
aura pas de baisse d'effective
du fait de la numérisation et de ses
progrès
qui rendent eux-mêmes de vrais services
au contraire il y aura une meilleure
disponibilité de nos agents pour être au
contact direct des
usagers en particulier lorsqu'il faut y
passer un peu de temps dans des cas
complexes au d'états sociaux on en a
dans tous les pays même dans les pays
développés donc ça permettra plutôt un
meilleur service comme moins bon service
je vais vous rassurer vraiment sur ce
point monsieur sénateur ganter vous êtes
interrogé sur l'aide sociale à
l'étranger nous maintenons une capacité
d'intervention en bénéfice de nos
compatriotes en difficulté j'ai donné
quelques chiffres tout à l'heure avec
une assez forte augmentation des
différents volets ressortissants des
dispositifs d'aide sociale et compris
des choses que nous ne faisions pas
jusqu'ici sur
l'aide publique au développement
où on suis-je où on suis-je
et notamment
le sénateur thémal s'interrogeait sur la
taxe sur les transactions financières
vous connaissez notre réponse parce que
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de la donner
dans une autre assemblée dans un autre
cadre nous raisonnons plus par rapport
au crédits disponible et non pas
particulièrement sur l'origine de ce
crédit taxe ou crédit budgétaire et donc
dans dans ce cadre le plafonnement 700
millions d'euros des crédits issus des
deux taxes ne posent pas de problème
particulier
sur la politique française en général
d'aide de développement monsieur
sénateur et
la les directions les orientations qui
doivent être donnés par le suicide je
peux vous informer que Madame la
première mise sera donnée son accord
pour une réunion du suicide
dans les semaines ou peut-être les mois
qui viennent mais c'est un point acquis
ça me semble comme vous bien nécessaire
en particulier en début de nouvelles
législatures et de nouveaux mandat
président il le fallait d'autant plus
que le Cécile ne s'était pas réuni pour
longtemps j'ai plaidé aussi auprès du
président de la République pour que un
comité du développement se réunissent à
son niveau il en a accepté le principe
je crois avoir oublié quelques questions
pardonnez-moi
sur la trajectoire financière de la BD
nous nous sommes à l'objectif qui était
fixé par la loi de programmation 2022
avec
5,5% de notre PIB
oui pardon mais donc nous tenons
l'objectif et c'est un objectif qui
n'avait jamais été atteint ensuite
la loi informée un vœu pour l'avenir je
ne peux pas le réaliser au-delà des 0,50
mais contenu de la reprise économique
2022 de l'augmentation importante de
notre PIB en soirée encore plus si on la
compare à d'autres pays notre aide au
développement a pu considérablement
augmenter j'ai donné le chiffre tout à
l'heure en volume et donc derrière ces
chiffres il y aura des bénéficiaires je
me réjouis tout comme vous même
souris je crois avait évoqué le Burkina
Faso
et les droits des collages pardonnez-moi
de ne pas l'avoir noter moi-même sur le
Burkina Faso
d'être budgétaire puisque nous apportons
une aide budgétaire à ce pays
parmi la gamme d'Inde que nous lui
portons une aide humanitaire ça fait
partie des instruments ponctuels d'appui
à un état en difficulté il s'agit pas
forcément d'un soutien
récurrent il y a pas automaticité du
maintien mais ne pas apporter d'appui là
comme ailleurs serait chantée de dire ne
pourrait qu'à croître la fragilité
d'État dont il n'est point besoin de
démontrer qu'ils sont particulièrement
fragiles ceci dit je vous répond plus
précisément ensuite
aux nouveaux coups d'État qui se produit
tout récemment il n'y a pas de décision
pour le moment qui était pris sur le
maintien et les formes de la poursuite
de notre aide à ce pays donc je serai
appelé à vous en reparler sur les droits
des col ils sont en effet comptabilisés
dans la et on applique les règles
de l'OCDE donc du Comité d'aide au
développement de CDE pour les
revaloriser
je crois vraiment un peu vite mais ne
pas avoir oublié trop de questions merci
Madame et la deuxième série de questions
sur des questions minutes donc je
demande à nos collègues et gars à la
liste de bien vouloir synthétiser leurs
pensées et donc tout de suite Joël
gariaume
oui merci monsieur le Président Madame
la mini je suis rapporteur de le dieu
visuel public extérieur
budget dont le budget ne fait pas partie
officiellement ni de la mission action
extérieure de l'État ni de l'aide
publique au développement alors que bien
évidemment les enjeux sont très liés
alors tout d'abord un satisfait site
puisqu'il y a eu une augmentation pour
le budget de France médiumonde par
exemple qui est passé de
284,7 millions contre
254,2 millions précédemment mais les
taxes sur les salaires la fin de la
déductibilité de la TVA liée bien sûr la
fin de la redevance font que ces
augmentations n'ont pas de véritables
incidence et qu'on en arrive
quasi statu quo pourtant jamais
l'audiovisuel extérieur n'a revêtu
autant d'importance vous l'avez rappelé
nous sommes au coeur d'une guerre
informationnelle et les enjeux de la
diffusion d'une information libre et
indépendante sont considérables et
mériteraient un renforcement budgétaire
les autres États l'ont bien compris et
ont des moyens très supérieurs aux
nôtres à titre d'exemple la BBC qui émet
en 41 langues étrangères nous seulement
en 20 langues vous le savez au Mali en
Russie il y a eu un blocage de France 24
alors que plus qu'ailleurs il y a ce
besoin d'une information libre
indépendante il nous faut donc adopter
des stratégies de contournement qui ont
un coût bien sûr il y a aussi peu de
synergie entre le reste de la diplomatie
culturelle et d'influence et il faudrait
encore renforcer les liens entre nos
instituts et nos alliances qui doivent
être des vecteurs de promotion de notre
audiovisuel public alors très rapidement
puisque j'ai très peu de temps nous
avons vraiment un réseau remarquable
avec des opérateurs un personnel
extrêmement compétent qui ne ménage ni
leur temps ni leurs efforts mais tous
sont bien sûr très inquiets fassent une
possible fragilisation du système suite
à cette fin de la devants nous avons
déjà subi des sacrifices des fermetures
de diffusion pour raison budgétaire
pendant certaines périodes dans certains
endroits nous avons eu la chance d'avoir
des apports ponctuels je pense à
l'apport de la FD de 50 millions d'euros
que je remercie pour cela mais je crois
que nous devons vraiment réfléchir un
moyen de renforcer le système en le
périnisant alors je sais que vous n'êtes
pas là depuis très longtemps vous n'avez
peut-être pas eu le temps de vraiment y
réfléchir mais je pense que ce serait
vraiment extrêmement important en
liaison avec votre collègue ministre de
la Culture nous devons vraiment faire un
effort aujourd'hui c'est extrêmement
important regarde la crise géop actuelle
merci Madame la Ministre merci Joël
Pascal alizat merci monsieur le
Président le ministre vous avez évoqué
question de sécurité notamment
l'ambassade de France à Islamabad où
j'ai eu l'occasion de me rendre à
plusieurs reprises la coalition
politique au Pakistan a changé il y a un
nouveau gouvernement depuis plusieurs
mois visiblement on sent une tendance à
se rapprocher un petit peu de l'Occident
et notamment de de la France ils ont
pris aussi des positions plutôt
intéressantes sur le conflit qui se
déroule actuellement en
Ukraine on voit que le grand voisin
indien est quand même plus de
difficultés à choisir à choisir son camp
j'aurais voulu madame la ministre vous
entendre quelques minutes sur ce sujet
s'il vous plaît
merci merci Pascal Olivier Cadic
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre votre prédécesseur Jean-Yves Le
Drion avait mis un terme à la baisse des
moyens du cadorcet avec la création de
106 au TP une première depuis 1993 vous
engagez un nouvel élan pour votre
ministère dont nous nous réjouissons
votre Punch est relayé avec beaucoup
d'efficacité par la porte-parole du Quai
d'Orsay pour relever les défis liés à la
lutte informationnelle pour lutter
contre les opérations de désinformation
et de propagande hostile vous avez
annoncé augmenté de 2,5 millions d'euros
les moyens de la direction de la
communication et de la presse quels sont
les autres services du quai affectés à
cette lutte informationnelle dont vous
avez fait état comme vous l'avez dit
aider les Français d'étrangers c'est
également développé de nouveaux services
comme l'expérimentation du
renouvellement des passeports sans
comparution prévus l'année prochaine au
Canada et au Portugal j'en suis ravi les
Britanniques le font depuis longtemps
c'est une proposition une approche que
nous avions soumis à Jean-Baptiste
Lemoine lors de sa nomination il y a 5
ans par contre comme je l'observe pour
le service la France consulaire la
plateforme téléphonique centralisée
c'est souvent repoussé en réponse à ma
question sur France consulaire l'an
dernier François Delattre ici nous
promettait qu'elle serait étendue dans
toute l'Union européenne d'ici la fin de
cette année et qu'elle serait étendue au
monde entier d'ici à 2023 je comprends
d'après votre intervention que ce ne
sera plus le cas comment expliquer ce
nouveau report d'expérience la mise en
oeuvre de nouveaux services consulaires
prend de longues voire de très longues
années pour ne pas rester les simples
spectateurs de l'action du gouvernement
et assumer notre mission de contrôle de
son action pourrions-nous envisager une
loi de programmation consulaire qui nous
permettrait d'appréhender l'évolution du
réseau consulaire dans le temps enfin un
message qui relayera je le sais le veut
de notre Président nous souhaiterions
que notre présence soit plus affirmée en
Amérique latine nous avons rencontré
l'ambassadeur du Brésil avec plusieurs
collègues à midi la France est le
troisième investisseur au Brésil à
l'heure où la balance de notre commerce
ext inquiète la clairvoyance voudrait
que nous nous saisissions mieux de
nombreuses opportunités offertes par
notre voisin avec lequel nous partageons
la plus grande frontière terrestre je
vous remercie merci Olivier Michel
gréaume
merci monsieur le Président excusez-moi
madame la ministre si je reviens sur le
sujet en complément de mon collègue
Rachid temal concernant la taxe sur les
transactions financières françaises dont
je me permets de rappeler l'objectif
principal est de faire participer le
secteur financier au redressement des
finances publiques de la France et
tenant compte du compromis de la
Commission européenne sur le sujet qui
épargne
99% des transactions à cause du faible
taux de la taxe et de l'assiette vous
venez de les entendre que vous n'avez
pas besoin de ce levier pour augmenter
les crédits mais les recettes faudra
bien les récupérer quelque part à un
moment donné et comment ne pensez-vous
pas qu'au vu de l'urgence sociale
environnement énergétique il serait
souhaitable de la réhausser cette taxe
française de 0,3 à 07%. merci
merci Michel brièveté Jacques le nez oui
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre
notre aide publique au développement ce
qu'on sente sur le continent africain or
l'image de la France y est altérée dans
de nombreux pays notamment sous
influence étrangères et en particulier
russe cette dégradation des relations
franco-africaine a-t-elle un impact sur
la réalisation des projets financés
devons-nous développer notre aide
publique comme un levier d'influence à
part entière et puis lors des crises
internationales je pense en particulier
au retour des talibans Kaboul les
demandes de visa pour la France auprès
des consulats se multiplient serait-il
envisageable dans le cas de demande
croissante de renforcer temporairement
les équipes populaire pour faire face à
l'afflux de cette demande et de les
instruire
merci Jacques Isabelle Raymond pavéro
madame la ministre sur le plan
diplomatique la Russie a renforcé ses
liens avec la Turquie qui représente un
enjeu majeur du fait du contrôle turc
des détroits séparant la mer Noire de la
Méditerranée sur le plan militaire la
coopération ruisseau turque s'est
traduite par l'acquisition en 2019 de
systèmes de défense anti-aérien par la
Turquie malgré l'opposition américaine
sur le plan civil les deux pays ont
renforcé leur coopération dans le
domaine énergétique avec l'inauguration
en 2020 du gazoduc turc stream reliant
les deux pays et avec la construction de
la première centrale nucléaire civile
turque à akuyu par l'énergéticien russe
rosatum à partir de 2018 concernant les
moyens vous avez évoqué le principe
d'une diplomatie innovante
quels sont ses moyens l'analyse et le
processus de notre diplomatie française
aujourd'hui merci
merci Isabelle Hélène Conway
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre sans surprise je vais vous
demander quelques précisions sur notre
réseau consulaire mais avant cela je
voudrais revenir sur un débat que nous
avons fait la semaine dernière 4 minutes
montrant en main puisque j'ai eu deux
minutes et vous deux minutes pour
répondre sur notre politique des visas
je pense que le sujet est suffisamment
grave et mérite un débat plus plus long
mais je voudrais simplement rajouter ce
que j'ai eu le temps de vous dire la
semaine dernière que aujourd'hui nous
sommes en train d'abîmer durablement
notre relation bilatérale sur l'ensemble
du continent africain et que quand vous
parlez de diplomatie vivante je pense
qu'il faudrait ajouter peut-être
diplomatie humaine et vous l'entendez
dans la bouche de mes collègues on
demande à nouveau de d'avoir des
personnels qui soient en face des
demandeurs et pas simplement une machine
sur laquelle on s'inscrit sur un sur un
ordinateur vous parlez aussi diplomatie
agile et bien si nous sommes agiles je
crois qu'il faut répondre quand nous
voyons que quelque chose ne va pas et en
ce moment cela ne va pas en tout cas
pour la politique des visas nous avons
énormément de gens en colère
déçus et qui aujourd'hui finalement
favorise et renforce sur les réseaux
sociaux ce sentiment anti-français dans
mon nombre de pays alors pour la
question les quelques précisions sur le
réseau consulaire enfin nous avons
des créations de postes et des crédits
supplémentaires je crois que c'est ce
que nous demandons de depuis très
longtemps donc je pense qu'il faudrait
pas gâcher finalement ce qui est une
opportunité qui sera peut-être unique et
pas nous nous attacher simplement à
réparer mais essayer d'avoir un petit
peu d'ambition et et finalement de
déployer ces personnels là où nous en
avons besoin et là je voudrais plaider
pour le réseau consulaire alors
j'entends que en effet la sécurité
mérite des personnels en plus grand
nombre mais sincèrement je ne pense pas
que dép des tasses que force ou des
forces d'appoint c'est le terme que vous
avez utilisé pour en effet essayer
d'accélérer
les
comment le traitement des demandes qui
sont faites en matière d'état civil
renouvellement de passeport et visa
suffira parce que ce sont des personnels
qui viendront de Paris qui seront
déployés dans différents pays qui ne
connaissent pas les deux bandeurs et
donc on ne connaissant pas les
demandeurs un certain nombre de
d'erreurs peuvent être commises peuvent
être peut-être faites donc j'aimerais
savoir si vous pouvez nous nous préciser
les modalités du déploiement et de leur
organisation également et cela déjà été
demandé le calendrier du du déploiement
des rendez-vous consulaires tout en
sachant que là aussi nous avons des gros
gros soucis puisque le système est
dévoyé par un certain nombre d'officines
privées qui aujourd'hui achètent et
revendent les créneaux de demande et
dernière question lors de la session qui
s'est tenue la semaine dernière de
l'Assemblée des Français de l'Étranger a
été évoqué leur volonté de d'être
associé aux états généraux de la
diplomatie je voulais savoir si vous
étiez favorable également si vous êtes
favorable à ce que les parlementaires y
participent merci
ça je crois que c'est acté j'ose espérer
merci
Hélène Pierre Laurent
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre une question
non budgétaire mais commandé par
l'urgence depuis 18 jours 50 prisonniers
palestiniens sont en grève de la fin
pour dénoncer leurs conditions détention
et parmi eux l'avocat franco-palestinien
salamouri
il y a eu de nombreuses interventions sa
faveur en France des interventions
officielles aussi de notre réseau
diplomatique
quelle initiative nouvelle entendez-vous
prendre pour empêcher une issue fatale
dans cette situation je rappelle que ça
la Mori est détenue depuis le 7 mars
2022 dans le régime de la détention
administrative c'est-à-dire une
détention qui est rendue possible en
Israël sans jugement sans procès sans
incrimination
quelle initiative nouvelle comptez-vous
prendre face à cette situation d'urgence
et puis pour prolonger la remarque
préalable faite par mon collègue André
Vallini et me féliciter moi aussi de
l'évolution
vers la signature de la nouvelle
déclaration internationale et oui pas
sur les armes explosives à en zone
peuplée déclaration internationale d'une
actualité majeure avec les guerres
actuelles
ma question est-ce que la France sera
représentée au plus haut niveau lors de
la déclaration
la signature lors de la signature de
cette déclaration internationale le 18
novembre à Dublin nous sommes plusieurs
parlementaires à nous rendre sur place à
cette date puisqu'il y aura aussi une
conférence parlementaire qui précèdera
cette signature donc est-ce que vous
comptez vous rendre à cette
cérémonie de signature de la nouvelle
déclaration internationale merci
merci Pierre enfin Yannick vogrenard
merci président madame la ministre une
question qui n'est pas budgétaire non
plus les femmes iraniennes depuis de
très longs jours subissent une
répression terrible en Iran la
Grande-Bretagne le Canada et les
États-Unis ont commencé à prendre des
mesures de rétorsion
vis-à-vis de des responsables iraniens
soit en gel d'avoir soit en interdissant
leur interdisant leur territoire
qu'elle va qu'elles vont être les
initiatives prises par la France
Les Affaires étrangères des 27 pays de
l'Union européenne sur unissent le 17
octobre au-delà de la position de la
France va-t-il y avoir une position
globale de l'Union européenne par
rapport à cette répression érotiques que
les femmes subissent en Iran merci
merci Yannick je voudrais pour terminer
à ajouter deux ou trois focus non
budgétaire mais profitez de votre
présence pour
reprenant du reste des observations qui
ont été faites sur la possibilité
consulaire et celle du visa attirer une
fois de plus votre attention sur la
dégradation des relations avec le Maroc
nous nous en sommes déjà entretenus nous
constatons que cette politique des visas
qui a été imposé dans les conditions que
nous avons et je connais je connaissais
à l'époque la position de du ministère
mais je voudrais savoir si il y a une
évolution à escompter il y a eu deux
visites successives au plus haut niveau
en Algérie une avec le président de la
République à laquelle j'ai participé il
y a eu celle de la première ministre
avec 16 ministres en Algérie tout ça va
dans le bon sens et nous ne sommes
absolument pas hostile une nette
amélioration des relations qui sont du
reste suivis par notre collègue archite
themal qui préside le groupe d'amitié
mais moi-même président le groupe
d'amitié du pays d'à côté je ne peux pas
ne pas évoquer les graves difficultés et
la dégradation de ces relations qui se
manifeste dans tout un tas de domaines y
compris dans le domaine économique et je
voulais savoir s'il y avait un point
d'évolution enfin par ailleurs je
voulais attirer votre attention sur deux
pays qui souffrent de manière
collatérale mais particulièrement grave
du conflit en Ukraine il s'agit de la
Biélorussie et de la Moldavie en ce qui
concerne la
Biélorussie c'est un pays qui
évidemment est entraîné du fait du
régime
de son de son chef d'État dans dans
cette guerre de manière de manière
incertaine mais en tous les cas avec des
conséquences pour la population le Sénat
a reçu le président du Sénat a reçu la
semaine dernière madame qui connaît
scaia qui a réussi ce tour de force de
réunir l'ensemble des oppositions je
rappelle que son mari est actuellement
incarcéré et torturé dans les jaunes de
lucachenko je voulais savoir si il était
possible comme c'est opposition le
demande à la France s'il était possible
d'envisager que
l'opposition
au régime biélorus puisse être accueilli
en tant que observateur au Conseil de
l'Europe de telle sorte qu'il retrouve
une instance où leur voix puisse être
entendues de la même manière en ce qui
concerne la Moldavie j'ai moi-même
l'occasion de rencontrer une délégation
importante de Moldavie ce petit pays
dont on parle peu qui est
très exposé j'allais dire par le
par le conflit
l'agression russe contre l'Ukraine ce
pays a des difficultés très importantes
notamment en matière de fourniture de
gaz puisque
la Russie a diminué pour une part
importante ça la distribution du gaz
rappelle que la Moldavie comptait à 100%
sur la faute du gaz russe et ils sont
dans quasiment l'impossibilité de payer
les sommes qu'on leur demande pour
trouver d'autres approvisionnements je
voulais savoir quelle mesure le
gouvernement français qui a été
sollicitée directement par la présidente
qui durait va bientôt revenir à Paris
ainsi que son ministre des Affaires
étrangères je veux savoir quelle mesure
vous comptez prendre pour aider la
Moldavie des déclarations très
encourageantes ont été faits mais je
voudrais savoir quels sont les actions
qui sont prises pour soutenir la
Moldavie voilà
il veut reprendre la parole on peut
rajouter à cette liste nous avons
auditionné ici un invitation de la
commission une femme députée afghane
il reste aujourd'hui quelques femmes
députées comme comme elle qui ont fui
leur pays et qui sont aujourd'hui en
Iran et notamment au Pakistan qui ont
obtenu en avril dernier pour certaines
un rendez-vous consulat de France et qui
n'ont plus de nouvelles depuis ces
femmes sont dans une situation de
précarité extrême et elle se disent que
quand leur visa expirera ce qui est
bientôt le cas pour être légitimement
accepté dans ces pays elles devront
retourner en Afghanistan et on peut
imaginer le sort qui leur sera réservé
donc là aussi je voulais ajouter à la
liste nous avons tous eu je crois nous
avons été très très émus par ce que
cette cette femme députée nous a dit
mais elle a malheureusement quelques
collègues qui sont aujourd'hui coincés
que nous devons secourir si nous le
pouvons voilà madame la ministre avait
la parole pour répondre à ces questions
vous pouvez les regrouper s'il y a des
sujets qui vous apparaissent commun
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs
tout d'abord madame la sénatrice vous
savez que je ne peux vous répondre qu'un
parfaitement puisque cette question ne
relève pas directement de la compétence
du ministère que je dirige mais vous
avez raison bien sûr nous avons besoin
d'une information libre et indépendante
vous avez entendu le président de la
République tout comme moi s'exprimer sur
ce sujet je crois que ça s'était vu
avait même été commenté lors de son
discours d'ouverture de la conférence
des ambassadrices et des ambassadeurs il
s'agit d'un instrument d'autant plus
important à nos yeux de Dieu visuel
extérieur de la France que c'est aussi
un instrument de rayonnement de la
langue française je vous ai attachée à
la Francophonie alors dans
la partie qui nous concerne donc pour
notre part dans le plan de résilience
démocratique que j'ai annoncé cet été
nous accroît notre soutien aux médias
locaux indépendant dans les pays où
c'est nécessaire et puis nos instituts
nos services culturels et de coopération
soutiennent l'Audiovisuel Extérieur de
la France j'entends votre appel à ce
qu'il le fasse encore plus nous leur
repasserons le message mais de
l'expérience que j'en ai ça se passe
plutôt bien quant au crédit question qui
ne dépend pas de moi je répondrai un
petit peu comme pour la taxe sur les
transactions financières que ceux qui
compte ce sont les crédits plus que leur
origine et il faudra suffisamment de
crédit pour assurer la qualité la
liberté l'indépendance qui est requise
pour que notre audiovisuel extérieur
remplisse ses objectifs
vous aviez posé des questions sur le
Pakistan et sur l'Inde effectivement nos
relations avec le Pakistan redeviennent
redevienne
progressivement plus plus normal après
une période où elle ne l'était pas
disons les choses avec l'arrivée d'un
nouveau gouvernement pakistanais nous
avons commencé de progresser sur un
chemin de confiance donc la France
souhaite avec le Pakistan des relations
apaisées constructives le président de
la République s'est entretenu en marge
de l'Assemblée générale des Nations
unies à New York avec le nouveau Premier
ministre pakistanais qui était je peux
en témoigner tout à fait sur la même
ligne et vraiment le même vœu pour des
relations de meilleure qualité entre nos
pays nous serons bien sûr exigeants dans
ce dialogue dois-je le dire puisque avec
nos partenaires de l'Union européenne
nous continuons de rappeler l'importance
que tous nos pays attachent au droit de
l'homme aux libertés au droit de
minorité à la liberté d'expression et
elle a lutte contre toute toutes les
formes de radicalisme mais nous sommes
aussi aux côtés du peuple pakistanais
vous l'avez vu puisque face au graves
inondations qui a fait vraiment été un
drame pour ce pays confronté à des
inondations d'une ampleur sans précédent
nous avons réagi tout de suite et
déployer en quelques jours sur le
terrain une aide humanitaire et une aide
en matériel ce dont le
Pakistan nous a été reconnaissant même
ci-dessous nous ne sommes pas bien sûr
les seuls à avoir fait cela
cette amélioration sensible des
relations de la France et du Pakistan
n'importe aucune conséquence négative
sur nos relations avec l'Inde notre
partenariat stratégique avec l'Inde et
d'une autre nature et des solides
nécessaires de progresser je me suis
rendu moi-même en Inde il y a quelques
semaines et nous avons pu comme vous
même noter une évolution politique au
regard des positions de ce pays sur la
guerre en Ukraine avec notamment une
prise de position publique du premier
ministre maudit à saint-marcande ou tout
aussi public une prise de position de
l'Inde lors de la réunion que j'ai
présidé le 22 septembre au Conseil de
sécurité des Nations Unies sur la
situation en Ukraine le rappel des
principes de la Charte et de
l'attachement de ce pays aux droits
international était tout à fait clair et
évidemment noté aussi par d'autres
partenaires qui ne sont pas de notre
continent
nous avons
l'intention de faire le meilleur usage
des moyens qui sont les nôtres ils ne
sont pas si considérables que nous
puissions tout faire mais en effet nous
avons décidé d'affecter des moyens
supplémentaires un dispositif de veille
qui n'existait pas avec 10 ou 20
personnes donc pour un ministère doté de
peu d'emploi comme le mien c'est un
effort considérable ça nous donnera
aussi une capacité d'action accrue sur
les réseaux sociaux et dans plus de
langues parce que souvent il y a la
question de la langue qui se pose nous
ne sommes pas les seuls à agir je le
disais d'un mot et je le répète des gens
dans
un peu plus spécialisée dans ce
peut-être la vocation mais je le
évoquerai pas ici néanmoins ce que nous
faisons au sein du ministère de l'Europe
et des Affaires étrangères sur ces
questions de mobilisent pas que les
quelques personnes dont je vous parle
puisque d'autres directions du Quai
d'Orsay sont appelées à amener leur
compétences et leur talents pour nous
aider à lutter mieux contre la
désinformation évidemment la direction
politique au premier rang de celle-ci et
les directions géographiques comme comme
l'ont dit sur le
consulaire
le déploiement se poursuit au rythme des
moyens là aussi j'ai cité tous les pays
qui ont pu déjà en Europe et au delà je
crois qu'il y avait la Moldavie donc je
réponds pas en partie à une question sur
laquelle je reviendrai je vous ai donné
aussi ce que nous ferons en 2023 si des
moyens supplémentaires venaient à nous
être confiés nous serions encore mieux
mais les choses se passent bien il y a
en particulier une grande satisfaction
pour nous à constater qu'on a toute
satisfaction de ce nouveau service qui
est de près de 90%
puisqu'il s'agit de nos compatriotes je
crois que c'est une performance qu'il
faut souligner parce qu'ils sont
volontiers exigeant donc nous ferons la
totalité de l'Union européenne dès que
possible nous y sommes presque en tout
cas puis nous allons poursuivre le
déploiement sur l'Amérique latine que
vous dire vous avez raison
la France doit s'investir davantage en
Amérique latine donc elle est proche
aussi de nos territoires d'une partie de
nos territoires
ultramarins c'est aussi l'intérêt de nos
entreprises de grands pays
économique émergence se trouve en nomade
latine il faut sans doute faire plus
c'est aussi une question d'influence on
a à l'heure actuelle quelques quelques
pays avec encore des sélections à venir
qui n'ont pas été les partenaires
aussi proche que nous
habituellement ces dernières années mais
nous verrons si une nouvelle
configuration politique permet de faire
plus
il
faut que la ministre s'en occupe et se
déplace et mobilise son ministre et ses
secrétaire d'État j'ai quelques projets
pour eux dont je leur ai déjà parlé avec
leur un sentiment madame la sénatrice
vous évoquez la hausse de la taxe mais
c'est plutôt un sujet
recette qu'un sujet dépense et je suis
ministère dépensier pas assez mais un
peu mieux que d'habitude et donc je
crois qu'il relève ce sujet de mes
collègues des finances et du budget plus
que de moi-même
madame la sénatrice la politique des
visas nous a en effet permis d'échanger
brièvement il y a une semaine
deux minutes seulement pour ma part mais
ce n'est pas moi qui fait le règlement
de l'Assemblée nationale de du Sénat
l'Assemblée limite également à deux
minutes les réponses comme les questions
donc je poursuis volontiers
c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est vrai il le
faut je poursuis volontiers avec vos
quoique trop brièvement sur un sujet
complexe vous avez rappelé que une
décision avait été prise en conseil de
défense en 2021 au mois de septembre
octobre moi je ne sais plus d'avoir une
politique des visa plus stricte
vis-à-vis à l'égard devrais-je dire de
certains pays qui eux-mêmes ne coopérait
pas suffisamment sur le volet retour
c'est-à-dire réadmission de leur
ressortissant en situation irrégulière
donc un lien avait été fait entre
l'octroi de visa des personnes en
situation régulière et un meilleur une
meilleure coopération sur les personnes
en situation irrégulière
nous sommes en contact étroit moi-même
pour la partie qui me concerne mon
collègue ministre de l'Intérieur pour le
volet migratoire de la politique des
visas puisque nous sommes conjointement
responsables de la politique des visas
sur les pays du Maghreb en particulier
je comprends que c'est conversations
bien avancées avec la Tunisie
ont avancé monsieur sénateur vous êtes
comme nous à peine de retour du
déplacement de la première ministre en
Algérie bien avancée également avec
l'Algérie quoi que nous attendons tout à
fait précise et tout à fait clair les
réponses des autorités algériennes aux
questions qu'il y avait été évoquées
entre le Président de la République et
son homologue à la fin du mois d'août
sur notamment des formalités
plus ouverte pour ce qui concerne
l'obligation de test PCR qui est un
moyen de contournement
assez diffusé non nombre de pays pour ce
soustraire aux obligations de retour
pour permettre des vols de quelques
personnes et non pas
étrangers en situation régulière un par
un et puis sur les documents à présenter
nous avons présenté ce qui résultait des
conversions du président de la
République et de son homologue et nous
attendons des réponses du nouveau
ministre algérien de l'Intérieur qui
vient de changer ce qui explique
peut-être que quelques semaines se sont
écoulées entre la visite présidentielle
et la visite de la première mise sans
que nous ayons encore enregistré la
réponse des autorités algériennes et
puis sur le Maroc nous sommes également
en conversation avec ce pays pour
obtenir le même résultat c'est à dire
que les retours des personnes en
situation irrégulière soit plus fluide
vous vous souvenez que le nombre de visa
émis ceci dit
a repris tout en restant dans la période
post pandémie inférieure au nombre de
visa 2019 les chiffres montrent qu'ils
sont encore inférieurs bien que nous
ayons repris vous avez ok madame la
sénatrice et difficultés et des retards
il y en a dans un certain nombre de pays
mais ils sont localisés dans ce que nous
allons faire je l'ai déjà annoncé c'est
la création d'un Centre de soutien pour
aider ceux des consulats qui sont
difficultés particulières qui font face
en clair un afflux de demande là aussi
souvent une reprise des demandes poste
pandémie et
le système des taxes force si on est
dans des difficultés localisées reste le
meilleur moyen dans
un misère qu'il y a des moyens humains
contrats pour résorber ces retards et
nous allons bien sûr lutter contre les
officines qui est capable les
rendez-vous en mettant en place très
concrètement des dispositifs
informatiques pour empêcher les les
bottes de
automatiquement bloquer les créneaux et
au profit souvent de personnes qui ne
viennent pas les honorer
les États généraux mais je m'aperçois
que je réponds dans le désordre ce qui
n'est pas bien les États généraux
associeront ils sont encore en
configuration mais la semaine prochaine
vous aurez plus de plus de détails
associés rond je l'ai dit je vous répète
volontiers des personnalités de
l'extérieur et bien sûr des élus dont
des sénateurs si vous le souhaitez
vous-même comme je vous en fais la
proposition
pardon
et des élus de levure on va voir moi je
crois que je resterai sur l'engagement
que j'ai pris devant nos ambassadrices
et nous ambassadeurs de faire une
consultation large inclusive comme l'on
dit ouverte transparente et dans nos
rendrons compte en début d'année
prochaine dans ces résultats
vous avez ajouté madame massénatrice une
question sur les Afghans et les visas
afghan ne contribuons
afghaneux mais aussi
afghan parce qu'il y a également des
Afghans en difficulté nous continuons à
attribuer des visas pour asiles qui est
un système unique au monde pour
l'Afghanistan depuis samabad et depuis
des rangs donc atterrant vous avez
raison la situation est
volatile et peu perturber le bon
fonctionnement du service des visas dans
la situation actuelle nous avons parfois
des réductions de personnel mais nous
faisons au mieux pour continuer à
attribuer ces visas qui sont bien utiles
et tout à fait unique dans leur genre
monsieur sénateur Laurent vous m'avez
interrogé sur la situation de Monsieur
Amaury
je réponds régulièrement
celles et ceux qui m'écrivent qu'il
s'agissent de sénateurs ou d'autres
parlementaires nous sommes pleinement
mobilisés pour que les droits de
Monsieur Amaury soient respectés
notamment qu'il bénéficie de toutes les
voies de recours dans la situation qui
est la sienne et nous avons demandé à
tous les niveaux de l'État y compris le
présente la République dois-je le
rappeler à ce qu'il puisse être libéré
aussitôt possible nos consuls à
Jérusalem et à Tel Aviv sont allés lui
rendre visite à plusieurs reprises cinq
fois et tout récemment encore la famille
de Monsieur Amaury a été reçu de
nombreuses reprises toutes dernièrement
encore c'était le 3 octobre et j'ai
demandé d'ailleurs à ce qu'elle soit
reçue à nouveau compte tenu de la grève
de la fin qu'il a entamé et de la
semaine qui s'est écoulée entre le 3
octobre et le jour où je vous parle mais
donc notre ligne est claire nous lui
apportons tout le soutien nécess il doit
pouvoir être libéré et mener une vie
normale là où il le souhaite c'est à
dire je comprends plutôt à Jérusalem
qu'en France quoi que il soit également
français nous demandons aussi à chaque
fois que son épouse et ses enfants
puisse lui rendre visite
vous avez également demandé qui serait
la signature la signature le 18 novembre
à Dublin nous n'avons pas encore défini
le niveau de participation je ne
pourrais pas m'y rendre moi-même parce
que je serai dans d'autres obligations
à ma connaissance tous nos partenaires
n'ont pas non plus définis leur niveau
de participation donc si vous le
permettez je vous en rendrez compte tous
ne l'ont pas fait je vous en rendrai
compte quand une décision sera prise
je crois que j'ai oublié une question
sur l'Iran mais je ne me souviens plus
qui l'avait posé moi de cela
il y aura une réunion en effet lundi des
ministres des Affaires étrangères de
l'Union européenne et nos formaliserons
je crois pouvoir le dire même si nous
nous sommes pas lundi 17 mais uniquement
mercredi 12 il y aura l'adoption de
sanctions contre les responsables de la
répression en Iran il y a eu un accord
technique hier ou avant-hier donc je ne
vois pas de difficultés malgré les les
pressions de la part de l'Iran qui
s'exerce pour
considérer que nos positions constituent
de l'ingérence ce qui n'est pas le cas
puisque nous ne faisons que rappeler à
l'Iran qu'il a souscrit des obligations
internationales en souscrivant un
certain nombre de conventions notamment
sur les droits civils et pratique la
convention 66 des Nations Unies et qu'il
est nécessaire que les rangs respecte
ses obligations donc
sous réserve vraiment d'une surprise que
je ne vois pas du tout venir
confirmation le 17 octobre enfin
monsieur le président sur
la politique des visas mais j'ai répondu
assez largement et les troubles que cela
peut
occasionner
permettez-moi de redire que des progrès
réels sont faits dans les dans les
contacts le mises intérieur doit avoir
avec ses homologues pour pouvoir revenir
à un dispositif
antérieur à celui de 2021 je pense être
en mesure de vous dire que
des décisions seront proches même si
elles ne m'appartiennent pas puisque la
décision avait été prise en conseil de
défense et sera prise vraisemblablement
conseil de défense cela Biélorussie nous
soutenons
l'opposition Belarus nous avons appelé
aussi par voie tout à fait officielle la
Biélorussie à ne pas
apporter davantage de soutien à
l'agression russe elle est sous sanction
et d'autres sanctions supplémentaires
donc suivraient si elle devait apporter
un soutien supplémentaire nous soutenons
l'opposition démocratique
j'ai reçu moi-même madame chicanovskaïa
elle a été reçue également au Parlement
et nous avons noté sa demande que
l'opposition démocratique de Biélorussie
puisse être reçu comme observateur au
Conseil de l'Europe je lui fais part de
mon accord pour le porter devant du
Conseil dur de l'Europe mais ce n'est
pas une décision française enfin la
Moldavie qui bénéficie du service France
consulaire donc c'est une première aide
de qualité
à et mérite toute l'attention est au
soutien de la France vous souvenez
monsieur le Président que dans les
décisions prises à la réunion informelle
de Prague de la communauté politique
européenne l'une des décisions qui a été
prise et de
d'accueillir la candidature de la
Moldavie pour une autre réunion de la
CPE et puis nous réunirons en France à
Paris au mois de novembre une conférence
de soutien à la Moldavie qui est dans
une situation de fragilité que l'on sait
sur le volet énergétique mais pas
seulement sur le volet énergétique donc
ça demeure une priorité notamment pour
l'aider et la consolider face à la
Russie au problème que la Russie pose
tous les États de la région je remercie
superbe
question
après le départ de la mini chez une
communication intérieure à la Commission
à faire
une bref question comme vous le savez
sans doute un ancien militaire français
prénommé Philippe François a été
incarcéré actuellement à Madagascar pour
des 10 ans de prison dans des conditions
absolument terribles dans une des
prisons les plus
les plus dégradées au monde
François
Ruffin monsieur Ruffin ambassadeur au
Sénégal a pris la présence du comité de
soutien pour l'instant c'est le silence
radio on n'a aucune information sur
cette question c'est le Quai d'Orsay
semble extrêmement discret sur ce sujet
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire
quelques mois si vous pouvez pas le
faire là on peut le faire après mais je
pense que ce cas mérite une attention
particulière merci Madame
je vous en prie
monsieur Center ne doutait pas même si
les expressions publiques
des ambassadeurs sont parfois plus
contraintes que ça des anciens
ambassadeurs là comme ailleurs que le
Quai d'Orsay et son ambassade est
totalement mobilisé à son soutien nous
considérons que son incarcération
d'arbitraire et nous agissons en ce sens
je n'en dirai pas plus mais je peux vous
l'assurer auprès des autorités malgaches
comme nous le faisons pour tous nos
ressortissants
merci Madame la Ministre puisque c'est
audition touche à sa fin je me réjouis
encore et je pense que c'est un avis
partagé par nos collègues de voir un
budget en progression ça faisait bien il
y a bien longtemps que cette bonne
nouvelle ne nous était pas arrivé ceci
posait nous restons tous les uns et les
autres dans un contexte international
particulièrement défavorable donc c'est
une raison supplémentaire pour renforcer
notre outil diplomatique dans ces
différentes composantes vous avez vu que
nos collègues ont des questions assez
précises on vous reverra régulièrement
comme l'on faisait avec votre prédicaire
pour avoir un état du monde et je pense
que cette ce dialogue est important vous
allez vous avez aussi la courtoisie de
nous accueillir prochainement pour un
échange un peu plus à bâton rompu en
tous les cas
je veux vous remercier pour la précision
de de vous répondre et vous dire que
partout il faudra aider le Quai d'Orsay
mais aussi
activité et de développement le Sénat
sera là à vos côtés
je pense que c'est une nécessité nous
avons une connaissance assez précise de
ces sujets la présence de sénateurs de
Français de l'étranger faire remonter un
certain nombre de questions aussi qui
méritent d'être prises en compte donc
merci pour ces précisions et puis à très
vite puisque nous nous verrons
prochainement merci à votre équipe qui
manifeste comme la précédente beaucoup
d'ouverture et d'attention et de
bienveillance à l'endroit du Sénat et
nous vous en remercions
deux minutes pour mes collègues je
raccompagne la ministre et je reviens